c'était quelques heures après la
découverte d'un nouveau foyer de
contamination à pékin des résidents que
l'on réunit pour les placer en
quarantaine
c'est dans ce marché que tout a
recommencé 106 cad qu'ovide 19
répertoriés en cinq jours après deux
mois de calme plat je suis un peu
inquiète
en fait non très inquiète 17 retraités
moi je suis sous le choc
c'était censé être terminé ce qui est
terminée pour l'adolescent de 14 ans
comme pour les écoliers ce sont les
cours les écoles primaires et
secondaires de pékin referme leurs
portes pour permettre davantage de
télétravail et ne pas accélérer la
transmission du virus
l'origine de la nouvelle éclosion est
incertaine l'hypothèse d'un saumon
contaminés et privilégier une trentaine
de quartiers sont jugées à risque à
pékin dans les plus touchés les
résidents peuvent seulement être
ravitaillés mais pour eux interdiction
formelle de quitter la ville terminées
les voyages non essentiels pour les
quelque 20 millions de pékinois pour
partir il faudra montrer un test négatif
des sept derniers jours
quatre vingt dix mille sont réalisés
tous les jours pour éviter que cette
éclosion ne se transforme en retour à la
case départ si mathieu frost radio
canada montréal